pleased to say that the immigration
Minister Robert generick is joining us
now good morning to you thank you good
morning so much to talk about so little
time to do it let's go straight into
shamima begum should we she's the is
bride she wants to be a Brit again why
won't we let her
well it's difficult for me to comment
I'm afraid okay because we're waiting
for the Court's judgment later today uh
once we hear that then I'm happy to come
on your program and speak to you but I
do think it's a fundamental principle
there will be cases rare cases but there
will be cases where people do things and
make choices which undermine the UK
interest to such an extent that it is
right for the Home Secretary to have the
power to remove their passport we'll
have to see whether the court ultimately
supports the decision of the former Home
Secretary to do that in this case is
there ever room to reconsider though
when um teenagers make bad mistakes
well I think you should always have an
open mind but it depends on the scale of
the mistake and the harm that that
individual did or could have done to UK
interests abroad but I don't want to
comment too much on on this case if
that's okay because we'll find out later
today what the Court's decision was
something you might want to talk about
is brexit are we doing
no we're not we have a settled position
there was a long debate as you well
recall and there were respectable
arguments on both sides as to the degree
of relationship that we had with the
European Union but we chose one in 2019
and 2020 when Boris Johnson signed the
deal with the European Union which was
very clear there wouldn't be
jurisdiction of European judges in the
UK we wouldn't be paying money to the
European Union and there wouldn't be
freedom of movement and those
fundamental principles are the ones that
will govern our relationship going
forward so I don't know where the story
came from in the Sunday papers it's not
one that we recognize and we're going to
stick with the relationship that we've
secured that doesn't mean that we're not
interested in improving our trading
relations with the European Union or
indeed in my sphere are security and
migration partnership with the European
Union as you saw with the deal that we
were able to strike with the French
recently but we're not going to reopen
the discussions that we had a few years
ago we have a settled View and we're
moving forwards on that basis so could
we potentially restart payments to the
EU in order to improve that trade deal
no we've no intention of doing that as I
said money free movement jurisdiction of
uh European judges these are really
important things that were discussed at
length within the conservative party
within the country a few years ago we
chose our position I think it's broadly
the right one because we did that for a
reason we did that so that the UK the
fifth largest economy in the world
wasn't subject to foreign judges or
rules and regulations coming out of the
European Union could embrace the
opportunities that came with brexit and
you heard in the budget the chancellor
saying that we would be doing that in
crucial areas for the British economy
like life sciences like green
technologies like Advanced manufacturing
and financial services and that really
should be our Focus right now how do you
grow the British economy and ensure that
we are one of the most Innovative
countries in the world using our ability
to set our own laws at a faster pace and
in a smarter way than a big trading
block like the European Union is able to
do so the head of the CBI says in order
to improve growth we need to increase
migration
yeah I don't agree with that we listen
to the business Community obviously and
we're aware of certain skill shortages
and we want a pragmatic sensible
relationship with business you see that
in some of the Visas that we've
established in recent years like the
Health and Social care visa for example
that's enabled thousands of doctors and
nurses and care workers to come into the
country to help support the NHS but
overall our ambition is to reduce net
migration we think that's what the
British public want that was one of the
driving forces in the votes to leave the
European Union back in 2016 and it's
simply not true to say that we've
adopted a sort of closed-door approach
since then in fact last year 300 000
work visas were issued for people to
come into this country they were issued
to people who had a certain living
standard so they could look after
themselves and not rely too heavily on
the state and they're issued to people
who are working in what we call shortage
occupations I think that's the right
approach rather than drawing on Lower
skilled workers if I was a business
manager I would be looking to the
British Workforce in the first instance
seeing how I could get local people into
my business train them up skill them to
do the job and remember okay there are
five million economically inactive
people in this country and the
government's first duty is to help as
many as them as possible into the
workforce do you listen to the British
people I hope so that's my job as a
politician okay 54 say that brexit was a
mistake
well that's a poll that you're referring
to there and polls obviously do come and
go the most important vote was the one
that happened back in 2016 when the
public voted to leave the European Union
I don't think if you asked people would
you like to go through the disruption
and the challenges that happened when we
were debating when and how to leave the
European Union all over again my
priority now as a member of the
government is to help this country
through a cost of living crisis ensure
that we grow the economy and to tackle
big issues like the migrant crisis in
the channel like public schools what's
going on with this um chap that died at
manston
well it was very sad obviously as
anybody's death was but as far as we
know and it's now a matter for the
coroner and the independent investigator
called the iopc who the home office
referred the case to as far as we know
this is an individual who got unwell on
arrival in the UK or was I well before
so he arrived not because of the
conditions at Manson well the coroner
will investigate that and so I don't
want to prejudge that but from what we
know today he certainly did not have an
infectious disease like diphtheria as
has been suggested in the press okay
talk to me about little our issue two
years old his family complain about mold
even before he's born and he dies
because of mold and his Housing
Association home how good I mean that
was under your watch how could that
happen yeah I think it's a desperately
sad case and it shows that some social
housing and in fact it's not related to
socialism because the the evidence
suggests that the private rental sector
actually has on average lower standards
than the social rented sector so housing
more generally there are unfortunately
far too many properties in this country
that don't meet a decent standard we've
done a number of things in recent years
to try to tackle that hopefully the most
important one will be creating a new
regulator for social housing I
established that as Housing section is
now being legislated for by my successor
Michael Gove in the House of Commons
that will ensure that residents voices
are heard because one of the things we
learned for example in the grenfell
tragedy was that too many people who
live in social housing feel ignored as
if they don't matter and their social
housing providers so long well we we've
established a regulator we've
established an entire new regulatory
regime which is all about ensuring that
people who are residents in Social
Housing Council housing or housing
associations can actually have their
voices heard and their complaints
properly investigated we're almost out
of time but I mean I've been looking at
some of the big earners in the paper
there's more morning former boss of
anchor housing 592
000 should these people be getting that
no I don't think they should be in when
I was housing Etc I called that out
repeatedly housing associations I think
in some cases have moved away from their
charitable and social purposes and have
become too large not sufficiently
focused on the interests and needs of
the resident where it began and as you
say some of the executive pay is off the
charts that needs to change Michael Gove
I think this week has written to all the
social care social housing providers in
the country raising that case and saying
that they need to improve standards and
refocus on where social housing began
which was providing decent quality
housing to people who are more
vulnerable in society rather than
becoming large businesses that are out
of touch we're out of time but um I'm
sure you'll be watching the England game
later on how will you feel if they take
the knee
I'm fine with that I think that that's a
choice for Harry Kane and the team as
indeed for for Wales as well these are
their choices it's not for the
government to to tell them what to do
and I think when you're playing in a
country like Qatar which does have
different standards in the way it treats
for example the lgbtq community uh it's
perfectly legitimate for the England or
Welsh team to to make that stand it's
amazing uh to talk to you um it's been
too long thanks for coming in so much
appreciated thanks a lot Mr